cette fin d'année 2010 9 a largement été
marqué par les mouvements sociaux cela
n'était pas arrivé depuis 2001
les policiers se sont mobilisés pour une
marche de la colère à paris les
yvelinois était du cortège forte
mobilisation également des agriculteurs
conditions de travail sentiment de
persécution ils ont bloqué les péages et
les routes yvelinoise pour même terminé
sur le périphérique parisien et les
hôpitaux - réaliser plusieurs actions
pour dénoncer leurs conditions de
travail de plus en plus difficile avec
par exemple cette opération à l'hôpital
mignot symbolisant la mort de l'hôpital
enfin et surtout la grève illimitée
contre le projet de réforme des
retraites
elle a débuté le 5 décembre et un pacte
grandement les transports les cheminot
de versailles se montre particulièrement
déterminé la suite c'est la continuation
de la grève
son renforcement et la question de sa
généralisation à tous les secteurs et
puis ma foi s'il faut faire la bûche de
noël sur les pics en france le conflit
est toujours actif en ce début janvier
une durée record et une dimension un
stère professionnels plusieurs actions
locales et notamment le 17 décembre
six cents manifestants se sont réunis à
versailles une réforme basée sur le
rapport du haut commissaire jean paul
delevoye
il est justement venu en débattre et
faire de la pédagogie à vélizy l'homme
d'état a depuis démissionné de ses
fonctions
nicole belloubet garde des sceaux a
rencontré les acteurs des quartiers de
reconquête républicaine attrape la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal s'est rendu auprès des
étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines sous la
thématique de la précarité étudiante
edouard philippe le premier ministre et
sa ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud ont lancé l'application mon
compte formation à guyancourt
enfin le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner a présenté son plan
anti communautarisme mur au début
décembre avant de revenir à la fin du
mois à magny les hameaux pour la
présentation du dispositif de
sécurisation de la nuit de la saint
sylvestre
mais l'événement qui a le plus concentré
de ministres dans le département c'est
malheureusement la santé du chapiteau de
chanteloup les vignes annonçant des
criminels sur un centre culturel
inauguré seulement un an auparavant
immédiatement la décision a été prise de
le reconstruire et pour cela l'état et
des collectivités locales ont assuré
leur soutien financier
vous savez quand on voit ça on se dit
mais ça va transformer durablement la
vie des gamins
c'est à dire qu'ils veulent il va plus
rien ne se passe et ça c'est pas
possible
plus de 700 entreprises au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
quatrième convention d'affaires sky
business day a permis quatre mille
rendez vous entre acteurs de l'économie
du territoire votées depuis 2010 est la
fusion des départements des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine n'est pas encore
effective
mais les travaux communs se multiplient
lagence d'insertion évinoise activity a
élargi son champ d'action aux hauts de
seine un portail internet commun aux
deux départements a été ouvert on est
plus fort à deux que tout seul
ce que nous voulons mettre en oeuvre
aussi bien à travers la fusion qu'à
travers les progrès que nous faisons
administrativement techniquement dans
cette fusion celle inverse
c'est donc de ces l'administration se
met au service de l'usager au service du
citoyen le syndicat mixte yvelines
numériques est devenue scène et vie
numérique
les deux présidents de départements ont
même été auditionné sur ce projet de
fusion à l'assemblée nationale enfin
l'université des mairies des yvelines
accueillait aussi les maires des
hauts-de-seine pour la première fois le
mercredi 16 octobre 259 mer des yvelines
et 36 des hauts-de-seine se sont
retrouvés à port marly le mois de
novembre a marqué un anniversaire celui
des 30 ans de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
de nombreuses communes l'ont célébré par
différents ateliers sur le camp
militaire de satory le quatuor à cordes
de l'armée de terre a donné une série de
représentations pour la première fois
ouverte au public
enfin côté sport le son troisième open
de france de golf s'est tenue au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est le belge nicolas colsaerts qui
s'est imposé sur le green
plus de 6000 personnes par jour sont
venues y assister